I've been asked before whether I would
consider a physics PhD to be worth it
and that's kind of a hard question to
answer because it's such a personal one
it really depends what you hope to get
out of doing a PhD I certainly wouldn't
recommend just jumping into one straight
after undergrad because you see it as
the next step or the next thing to do
I'd really consider why you're doing it
it can be a big cost to you in general
if you were to go and get a job straight
out of undergrad you would earn a lot
more money than doing your PhD for the
same amount of time so it really has to
be worth it in terms of do you think you
will make an excellent researcher do you
want to pursue a more academic line and
if you do then maybe consider it further
but here's some thoughts for my friends
who are all doing a PhD in physics at
the moment it might be a little bit
biased but here's what they had to say
there's a PhD worth it well as a PhD
student myself I would say yes mainly
because I think I like the challenge and
I like the problem-solving and the
skills that you learn from it are really
useful basically if you're interested in
figuring out more about the universe and
figure out how stuff works the phd's
really useful there's valuable things
that I've gained definitely getting a
new attitude to teamwork I mean you know
group assignments were always the worst
in undergraduate studies but being able
to work in a big group on so sometimes
it seems like your individual project is
not going to change the world right but
when you're working when your individual
project is part of a larger project and
that larger project has a very clear
goal of we're going to we're gonna work
really hard to try and figure out what
is going on with the inter nuclear
potential or something like some big
project which one person alone can't do
but you put a bunch of people together
and
and you can all work towards some common
goal that's something that has
definitely been worth it and then yeah
personally I've learned a lot of new
things I've gained a bit more confidence
in that I can't keep learning more thick
new things and I know how to learn so
for me so far it's definitely worth it I
think that's a matter of perspective
I've certainly drawn a lot from the
experience and a lot of people that I've
spoken to seem to be enjoying it in fact
on a recent survey from nature despite
all of the difficulties of doing
research something like 75 percent of
people are satisfied with the experience
so obviously there's something valuable
there and it is something that comes at
a cost but if that it cost buys you the
satisfaction of understanding something
complicated and answering questions that
nobody has asked before then you know
that's that's enough for me and that may
be if that's enough for you
of course it's absolutely worth it like
the amount of transferable skills that
you can get from a physics degree is
really mind-boggling especially nowadays
given it's a big data sort of economy
the amount of data that physicists
especially I guess like myself I'm a
nuclear physicist we have to deal with a
large amount of data that's a huge skill
to gain also plainly being able to
understand mathematical models being
able to write down a set of differential
equations that might model some scenario
allows you to go into economics to some
small degree if you want to as well so I
highly recommend a physics degree even
as a generalist degree like it's a
really good generalist degree I think
[Music]
you